they're tricks that you can use that
actually outsmart the tricks your brain
plays on you we live in a world where
people are addicted to their devices
you know today for 60 minutes turn your
devices off or don't look at your
devices
this is without a doubt the single
best financial decision i have ever made
in my life what i'm about to share with
you
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to make the
next
100 days the best of your life
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make five second decisions with mel
robbins
when you understand the power of a
five-second decision
and you understand that you always have
a choice to go from autopilot to
decision maker
everything in your life will change you
will be a different negotiator
you will be different in sales you will
be unstoppable in the gym
because you will realize the amount of
garbage
that you put in the way of your hopes of
your dreams of your potential of your
confidence of your courage
everything comes down to the decisions
that you make
we all know what to do none of us know
how to make ourselves do it
so um i started researching it
why does something so stupid work why
why does something so silly create such
powerful and profound change
well here's why the rule is a form of
metacognition
metacognition is a fancy pants terms
that means something real simple
you can outsmart your own brain in
furtherance of goals they're tricks that
you can use
that actually outsmart the tricks your
brain plays on you
in furtherance of a higher purpose we
all know this you can
you can restrain yourself if
uh you're in a situation that calls for
it you can jump into a raging river to
save your dog or your
kid you can direct yourself
in ways if it's important to you
and so the rule what it does is it does
something really
remarkable when you count backwards five
four three two one
what you're actually doing is you're
interrupting
what researchers call habit loops that
get encoded as
as closed loop patterns in your basal
ganglia that's the part of the brain
where your feelings where your emotions
every habit that you have which is
nothing more than behavior that you
repeat
that you don't even think about i've
heard it referred to as a gearbox
yeah to shift your attention from yes
and so when you go 54321
it interrupts what's going on here
that's spinning without you thinking
and it moves and awakens your prefrontal
cortex
so when you hit one your habit has been
interrupted so you've interrupted
self-doubt
you've interrupted maybe snapping at
your kids you've interrupted
the desire to grab for a drink you've
interrupted
uh procrastination you've also by
counting backwards
done an action it's awakened your
prefrontal cortex that is the part of
the brain that you need that's awake
when you're changing behavior when
you're learning new things
when you hit one it's also a prompt so
in the language of research
you'll hear people talk about starting
rituals
that is that is something that's proven
to help you learn a new habit the five
second rule when you repeat it becomes a
starting ritual
that triggers you to act with confidence
it triggers you that this is a moment
for courage
that triggers you to shift gears and
because you've also done the manual work
of awakening the part of the brain that
you need to change
you've set yourself up for success it
doesn't work if you count up
because you can keep going and also
counting up doesn't require focus
if you count backwards five four 54321
it
again awakens the prefrontal cortex and
it prompts you to move
rule number two make good financial
decisions with grant cardone
this is without a doubt the single
best financial decision i have ever made
in my life what i'm about to share with
you
cash is trash what you want is
cash flow you want cash
flow you want flows coming in that you
don't have to work far
do what you want go where you want say
what you want
pitch what you want the only way you can
do that
is if your time is independent
of your income when i was 29 maybe 30
years
old i realized there was no way i would
ever create wealth
with a job i also realized i would never
create wealth
if i owned a company if you want wealth
it will not be because you own a company
owning a company has nothing to do with
the creating wealth
so when i was 30 years old i started
shopping real estate on the weekends
i've never been to a real estate course
i've never read a real estate book
i was shopping houses i never bought
anything by the way
shopping shopping learning the language
finding out about financing
what's a good deal what's a bad deal
what's the difference between
residential commercial retail
shopping centers where's the money at
who's gotten rich with this
which which particular real estate works
okay so for 30 years now
i started with a single family house it
was 75 000
if you're taking notes do not
buy single family homes
if it's got one door live in it don't
own it
you do not want your money
sitting in a piece of real estate that
doesn't pay you
the house i live in today we rent
i rent where i live and i own five
thousand apartments that pay me every
month
if you don't find a way to make money
while you sleep
you will work until you die hey man
everybody how you doing buddy good how
are you you got a book coming out don't
you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number three focus
with robin sharma most people just show
up
at work most people just get through the
day
most people spend the best hours of
their best days
watching house of cards it's a good show
but
we live in a world where people are
addicted to their devices
you know today for 60 minutes turn your
devices off or don't look at your
devices
your devices your addiction to checking
every what's app that comes in every
notification from facebook
every social media post is costing you
fortunes of productivity
creativity impact and influence
when you focus monomaniacally on a
project or
a skill a neural pathway
gets set up around that one skill are
you with me show of hands
soccer player football player go to
practice deep practice every single day
you isolate a neural pathway every time
you practice your skill whether it's
leading whether it's
innovating whether it's managing change
whether it's communication
every time you turn off your phone you
get away from distraction because
every genius has one thing in common
extended
periods of time away from distraction
and interruption
so when you get away from distraction
and interruption and you focus on that
one
skill or that most important project
the neural pathway gets stronger and
stronger
and the more you practice the skill the
more that neural pathway gets
isolated now when it gets isolated
through deep practice every single day
in an undistracted environment
oligodendrocytes look at the person next
to you and say oligodendrocytes just do
that for me
a little participation here in dubai
please
okay so oligodendrostrites get triggered
and they release a fatty tissue called
myelin myelin
say that for me please myelin myelin
is thought to be by many researchers and
scientists on high performance to be the
secret of genius
wayne gretzky says i didn't skate to
where the puck was i
come on we're in dubai hockey is popular
now
no he said i didn't skate to where the
puck was i skated to where the puck was
going
steve jobs i could see around corners
messi bend the ball like beckham these
people were not naturally talented
they stripped away distraction they
developed a monomaniacal focus on
mastery
they did it over an extended period of
time they
did over an extended period of time and
what happened
their brain kicked in to create a
pharmacy of mastery
that every single one of you in this
room has rule number four
be positive with richard branson i'm
positive about
life generally and i generally feel that
you can you can
find ways of solving problems and making
things work and
you know i'm definitely a sort of glass
you know
nearly full kind of person rather than a
glass half full so
you know i think i think out of out of
being just a generally positive person
you could you can make positive things
happen rule number five
get a mentor with bob proctor for the
next few minutes i want to talk about
you
i want you to just think about you for a
moment i want you to think about your
life
i want you to think about how you're
living versus how you'd really
like to live just say
pay close attention to what we're doing
and you're going to find out
that you can actually create your own
economy
now i learned that many years ago when a
man told me
he said bob if you'll read this book and
do exactly what i tell you
you can have anything you want now i did
not believe that
but after talking to varela i believed
he believed it
guy was happy he was healthy he was
wealthy i was unhappy i was sick and i
was broke
i had no formal education i had no
business experience he said that doesn't
matter bob
what's happened in the past is the past
what happens in the future is based on
the decisions you make
now i said i know how to earn money i
know how to be happy and i know how to
stay healthy
if you'll do exactly what i tell you
your life will change
well you know it did over the next year
i multiplied my income
in fact my life changed so much
i made a decision on one thing from that
point on
i would always have a mentor i would
have some kind of a coach
and i would pick someone that knows how
to do what i want to do
and then i'd do exactly what they told
me and that's what i've done
and i've been doing that now for over
half a century i sat down and took a pen
out one day and said i'm going to build
a company that all
operates all over the world well right
now i'm broadcasting all over the world
and rule number six the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is build your own stage with beyonce
there's so many different ways to be
brilliant i believe
you and every human being is born with a
masterful gift
don't make the world make you feel that
you have to look a certain way to be
brilliant and no you don't have to speak
a certain way to be brilliant but you do
have to spread your gift
around the planet in a way that is
authentically
you to all those who feel different
if you're a part of a group that's
called other a group that does not
get the chance to be center stage build
your own stage
and make them see you your queerness
is beautiful your blackness is beautiful
your compassion your understanding your
fight for people who may be different
from you
is beautiful i hope you continue to go
into the world and show them that you
will never stop
being yourself that it's your time now
make them see now if you've ever been
called dumb
unattractive overweight unworthy
untalented
well so have i whatever you do
don't let negativity of people
projecting their own self-doubts on you
deter you from your focus i know those
moments are painful
and you're human and it hurts like hell
but now is the time to turn those
criticisms into fuel
and motivation to become a beautiful
beast
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through
and when you share with other people it
jumps to 95
chance your likelihood of following
through and so i want that to be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you we don't
change the people we hang out with
because we're afraid
we're afraid that we're not going to
find new people we're afraid that we
don't know where to find new people
we're afraid that we're going to get
rejected and judged by these new people
we're afraid that if we lose the people
who are
hanging around us right now that we'll
have nobody that we're starting over
from scratch and we don't know what to
do and
it's better to be with people who are
just okay than to be lonely and be by
ourselves that
that's the problem you're just afraid
but here's the thing if you don't
change it if you don't change your
circle you're never gonna grow
chances are right now you are the most
ambitious person that you know
you're the most ambitious person the
happiest person most positive person the
most
optimistic the most ambitious the most
loving caring big dreams person in your
circle
chances are that's you and that's
amazing that's an amazing gift that you
can give other people you can pull other
people up and you can support them and
cheer them on
but who's doing that for you who's
pulling you up who do you hang out with
who makes you feel like
you need to get better who's pulling you
into a different world who says hey
you can be more positive you can play a
bigger game you need to believe in
yourself more
who does that for you chances are nobody
that's the problem that's
also maybe why you're watching these
videos it's why i make these
videos on my channels because i want to
try to be that person for people i want
people to believe in themselves more and
content is definitely a way to do it
this is the starting point
but you have to decide that you're ready
to play a bigger game
and that comes with making changes in
your life and that comes with taking
some people
out of your life now doesn't mean you
cut them out completely maybe it does
maybe it doesn't you know if your mom is
always the one being negative and
telling you that you suck
or questioning you on things maybe you
don't want to cut her out of your life
but just because you're friends with
somebody in high school or kindergarten
doesn't mean that you should still be
friends now
a lot of us are in these relationships
out of convenience
just because it's how it's it's been
you've always been friends with this
person so you must stay friends with
this person
it doesn't mean you have to become
mortal enemies but you're going to
outgrow people think about how much
you've grown in the past 10 years
20 years think about me i'm turning 40
in may
so you know 20 years since university
the people who i was with in university
in
in 30 years since school man how much
have i grown in the past 30 years how
much have you grown in the past 20 years
how much have the people around you
grown probably not that much
and so if you keep growing growing
growing growing growing growing and
they're just kind of staying where they
are
you slowly lose things to be able to
talk about and connect over
and so you might pull them up a little
bit but you can only pull them up to the
extent that you've grown
and they're likely pulling you down in a
lot of areas
and so you have to do an audit my
recommendation is you do an audit you do
an auto in your life you do not know the
people around you
think about who you hang out with the
most start with the people like who are
you hanging out with the most
your friends your family people in your
social circle
people at work who are you hanging out
with the most and who actually gives you
energy
do it on it who gives you energy and if
they're giving you energy you want to
spend more time with them you want to
try to spend more time with them
and if they're sucking your energy dry
every time if you're leaving
conversation with people feeling
depleted negative pessimistic
man you really need to spend less time
with that person or just shut them out
of your life completely
because you living around negative
pessimistic people
is not going to let you go off and build
something amazing
if you want to know how to renew your
mind and break your mental barriers
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there when you use your body in a
certain way if i
sit like this i'm going to channel i'm
going to tap into a different channel
those waves than if i'm sitting like
this
we took 75 agents